[Music]  I'm dr. Shawn Murphy I have autism I can  help people with medicine but I made a  mistake the only question I have is who  exactly is to blame now is the time it  takes st. Bonaventure to the forefront  of the medical profession  you've exceeded my expectations but your  communication skills are sorely lacking  things might be more difficult to you  now I was honest it just made it worse I  have cancer I've got a long journey  ahead of me  I am the best oncologist around if you  think I'm gonna sit around and watch  you're mistaken how do you say goodbye  to someone who meant that much to you I  am damn smart and I am a damn good  surgeon and if I can't be those things  then I don't know who I'd be you'd be my  friend I have a neurological condition I  will always have it I don't view that as  a weakness he sticks to his [ __ ] and he  fights for he thinks is right they have  a solution  you didn't care that it might mean the  end of your career unforgivable  you